[Music]  Angelina Jolie spotted out for the first  time since filing for divorce from Brad  Pitt and only et has the pics the mom of  six was spotted out on Sunday with her  kids and brother touring a new house in  Malibu her back was to the camera so we  can't get a read on her face but she  kept it casual in an oversized to  sweater and sunglasses Brad Pitt has not  been spotted by paparazzi since Angelina  filed for divorce in September but et  has confirmed the actor has spent time  with his children the star had a  monitored visit with the kids on  Saturday October 8th but not all six  children were present Brad and Angie  came to a temporary custody agreement on  September 30th it's in effect until  October 28th  you